Japan, one of the world's most popular travel destinations,...
...relaxed its COVID-19 border restrictions...
...and reopened to foreign tourists after more than two years.
Businesses in the ancient capital, Kyoto, are hoping to welcome back visitors.
Gyokusen is a high-end kimono shop that combines traditional Japanese garments...
...with famous ink wash paintings to create one of a kind modern wear.
Without many tourists,...
...Gyokumei turned his kimono shop into a French restaurant...
...as a way to get some customers through the door.
Hotels have also struggled.
Takasegawa Bettei opened five years ago.
Sumio says business is just 10 to 30% of what it was before the pandemic.
Nishiki is a popular covered shopping street known as Kyoto's Kitchen.
The often crowded market discourages visitors from eating while walking,...
...plastering signs about the rules.
But now it may be taking a softer approach.
As tourists from both Japan and overseas...
...slowly start filling up the streets again,...
...shopping areas like Gion are gearing up for another boom.
Tsujiri Tea House was founded back in 1860.
During the COVID pandemic, it closed up shop and leaned into its online store,...
...but now these doors are wide open once again.